[Music]
this is usually the time of year when we
get a visit from our old friend minty
the candy cane who briefly he briefly
fell on the ground what he's famous for
here's the problem though minty was
always been played by one of our former
writers Brian McCann there he is yeah
Brian Brian was with our show for 17
years and then he moved on to greater
horizons unfortunately Brian now lives
over 3,000 miles away in New York City
now we tried to fly him here but it was
too expensive what kind of show do you
think this is the reason it's expensive
is because Brian insisted we fly him
first-class and that we purchase a
second first-class seat for his minty
costume yes he's gone insane so I am
very sorry to say this but it would take
a miracle to bring minty here tonight
yeah there's nothing I can do about it
I'm sorry my hands are tough
[Applause]
Thank You Mindy how in God's name did
you get here I stole your credit card
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
putting the can has Minzy to candy cane
[Applause]
in the face with a basket
[Applause]
Oh God
Oh God
[Music]
[Applause]
no one wants an upskirt minty that's
awful he whacked me in the face he
doesn't work here I know he doesn't work
that's a guy who doesn't work here ya
kidding me full in the face with his
wicker basket